any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
first i want to ask you as i ask all my
guests a couple of questions but but
first
talk about your origin story how you got
interested
in podcasting and how you got connected
to james altucher
and the other projects that you work on
what is it about podcasting in
particular
now you're on the other side of the
micro i'm i'm right here the engineer
not jay so jay
introduce yourself where are you from
what's your origin story
hi hi uh yeah so so my name is jay uh
i'm from malaysia
uh you know like james and i always have
this james created the origin story for
me all right so this is james version
i'm gonna tell james for a difference
james version is you know jim was
walking down the street in soho new york
and then he saw a chinese person sitting
in front of his
hotel and then he's like hmm this guy
can be my engineer i don't know any
chinese
i don't know i didn't know any english
and everything you know so i just
you know i just followed james you know
he looks like an honest person
with the hair and then you know and then
i learned all the english from
you know from james but yeah by by my
original
origin stories i'm from malaysia um
initially
my my dream my biggest dream is to win a
grammy
and i'm always a audio engineer uh by
heart so
you know i worked in studio for music
for post-production for tv
but uh one day this this is just pure
luck
james just came in the studio and then
uh so the the studio that i work in the
system is like
we got randomly assigned to sessions
so you know i just got assigned to james
sessions that time in my brain podcast
i thought is just like a radio drama do
you remember radio drama back in the 60s
yeah i don't remember but i know of them
yeah
yeah well but but you know like the the
80s doesn't really
the 60 doesn't really come to malaysia
until the 2000s
yeah so what happened is you know uh i'm
like oh this is just
another voiceover session for me i i
thought in my head i'm like so i just
set up i just sit there i just ready to
go and then you know james walks in with
um do you know jesse isler
i know the name so yeah so jesse is like
one of
james gas then um uh
and then you know they would just have
this fascinating conversations
and then i'm like this is great is this
podcast pasca a podcast podcast
so i just went out and told my studio
manager like hey you know every time
james
um jane comes and booked the studio
just assigned me on it you know like i
want to work with james i want to work
on these
awesome sessions so i've been working
with james since
and then the studio closed so what
happened when the studio closed
i just reached out to james i told him
you know the studio close
i would love to still work with you um
you know i can take on a role
like i know this i know the studio since
around the city i can help you
book any studio have you schedule
everything so you don't have to worry
about booking and scheduling
so and then i just went on become you
know become james uh
recording engineer then um and then
sooner or later all of a sudden just
became his uh assistant because i start
helping him with you know
with photos with any it needs that he
needs
and any scheduling that i can help and
james like hey
you know just just be my assistant and
also at the same time be the producer
for the show
so yeah the origin story into podcasting
so it's funny to me because a i got a
new idea for your first book which we
called losing the grammy
it worked for me uh and secondly how you
kind of preemptively and maybe the
reason that you guys resonate so much is
because you have
sort of a a rapport that's based on
similar
um you know kind of similar ideas that
you kind of presage this notion
of choosing yourself like you could have
just said oh like who am i and i
i you know the gatekeepers got to decide
but you went out there
and pushed yourself ahead and all of a
sudden that made all the difference in
the world
it is yeah because like see if i never
worked with gyms before
that wouldn't have crossed my mind so
like i learned so much just by working
for james um
during that uh i think it's only six
months before
the studio closed uh yeah she came at
the end of the studios uh
the studio live so yeah so like during
the six months and learn so much i
learned about negotiating and then about
choosing yourself you have to go out
there and the power of ask is
very very important because like
you know you just ask the worst thing
they can say it's no
right you know yeah so i just asked hey
you know
can you know i love working with you you
know i i
i think you'll kind i'm pretty sure
you'll like me you know
yeah and um and the dynamic with me and
james is that every time when we're in
the same room
when we first started working we didn't
really talk as much because i'm an
introvert myself
so he would just work on his stuff i
would just work on my stuff
and then you know we have small chitchat
and then we go back working
i think that that sort of kick off the
relationship in the sense that
i don't bother him if he's busy you know
like i'm not i'm not one of those
persons i have to talk to you
even though when you're working on
something so i think i think he liked
the the side of me uh or those
now have changed you know now i'm just
like every time jim's here just we just
talk about
anything we just talk about every i i
would just ask him any questions and
then he would
have an awesome answer that i'm like oh
that's cool yeah
and i look at it and i think wow you
know jay is one of james's most frequent
guests i mean you guys do
episodes they're supposed to be solo
episodes or just chances and then it's
jay
and and you have so much insight you
know it's just listening to
you know uh one where you did recently
and you're talking about like
you know people that chose their
artistic sensibilities
over choosing you know financial
remuneration
and you're like just like quoting all
these things like rocky five was about
that because one of the
people that you guys are i'm like how
does he know that like i didn't know
that
i'm from like 150 miles away from rocky
you know iraq it was failed though like
it was in malaysia during this whole
time like how could that possibly be
well the thing is like well the thing is
that's it because sometimes when
james says i talk we talk about rocky
sometime you know sometimes
it's like hey james have you seen this
about rocky and then we would talk about
it
and then jay sometimes james would be
like hey do you know about this and then
we'll talk about it so sometimes
like sometimes i learn news from james
and james
learn news for me i think james learned
a lot more pop culture for me and i
learn
news from him because you know i'm
obviously i'm a little bit younger than
james
so just tell him all the pop references
out there
yeah and uh and but the thing is it's
but
that's why i say you're so great because
you can keep up with james like a lot of
time i can't keep up with james like he
his thought process is so fast and so
out there i like i really can't
keep up that's why that's why i say i
always love listening to your
conversation with james because
you guys have such a it's like
i'm i'm still at you know in you know in
with intel
pentium 4 and then now you guys are
intel i7 or i9 you know
i've got a commodore 64 up here but the
the thing that i notice about
you and and you know we've gotten to
know each other and that's one of my
favorite things about coming on the show
is you and i get to chat
we email you i'm first of all you're
extremely generous uh but the other
thing is you're extremely curious
and you know as far as like listening
keeping up with the speed well one thing
that works for me is i'll listen to
uh james on 2x before right before i
come on the show i'll listen to james at
2x which is really really fast
but then when i speak to him at 1x it
sounds like i'm talking like
you know so that's one of my hacks
you've given me flooding hack but i want
to talk
about what what means the most to you
about audio
as a medium as opposed to video which
which uh
is a different is a different media i've
actually just taken my youtube videos
make sure i have good audio push it to
push it to audio as well
but but you focus on the audio uh
there's a concept in judaism which is my
language i know you're going to convert
to it after the circumstance
well tomorrow
i actually leave a blog like that uh i
think there's a what you got jewish
temple
yeah temple yeah yeah it's right across
from me okay
yeah i heard they have some of those in
new york city i'm not i'm not
the funniest thing is it's on the same
block as one of the biggest church
in my yep and then
my neighborhood is so jewish that the
dungeon donuts downstairs downstairs my
apartment
it's kosher it's kosher i am coming over
there man i haven't had a good dunkin
donuts as kosher in
many many years there aren't many in san
diego first of all there aren't very
very few dunkin donuts but in judaism
which you know undoubtedly you know from
your study of judaism
but these past years learning hebrew uh
we have like you know in catholicism
they have the our father prayer they
have a prayer
called our father it's called the
catechism it's like a statement of faith
of the religion that they believe god is
in heaven and you know his name is holy
and there'll be peace
in judaism there's an analog of that and
it's called the shema
and shema in hebrew means hear or listen
and actually
in the in this prayer itself or in these
words that we say every day three times
a day
it has the following phrase it says do
not follow
after you know listen follow your ears
do not follow after your eyes
or your heart that make you turn away
turn astray and i wonder you know
do you think that audio is deeper than
visual like we've all been attracted to
like you know the opposite sex or
whatever i don't care you know whatever
your choice is fine by me
but you know i'm not saying you jeff
just saying in general the listeners
that will listen to this
uh but my point is like we've all been
uh led astray by something that's
beautiful visually appeals to us
visually
and you never hear a politician like
politician goes down in a huge sex
scandal
because he listened to some you know
person's voice you know it's always
they followed after their eyes what is
it about audio
that is deeper that that stimulates the
brain so much more than the eyes
it's it's really funny because
uh i've been thinking about that
uh no i wouldn't say quite often uh a
little bit uh it's
it's that you know every time when you
put on headphones versus you are looking
at a screen
like even if you close your eyes you
like they like you know like the phrase
you can hear them in your head
you can't see them in your head but you
can hear them in your head you know
because if you're putting on the
headphones like
you feel like the person is right beside
you talking into your ear
yes when you see a monitor screen
[Music]
oh that's a layer of separations
uh with the visual i'm not sure if that
makes sense
yes yeah like i'm looking to i mean you
know i'm looking at you
in in in in the monitor it felt like
yeah you're there
and i can instantly tell you are not
beside me but if you're listening to
podcasts
if you close your eyes you can you
almost felt like
they are beside you you know that's why
they say the podcasting
is such a successful medium is because
when you listen
on your headphones it felt like they are
there
listening to you right i don't know if
you have this experience
if you look at if you follow one person
on youtube all the time
versus you look follow that person's
podcast all the time you feel closer
to him when you're listening to the
podcast rather than watching his youtube
yeah yeah because you can tell like he's
probably faking some stuff
on on on on visual you know like like
you said like um judaism they say like
visual can deceit deceive you
more than you know the audio can and fun
fact i actually
is attracted to voices
more than more than uh visual yeah
it actually does take place actually in
the orthodox judaism
you uh men and women are separated
visually but you're also not
supposed to hear women sing and i agree
with you you know you say oh that's
stupid that's so sexist
but you know it is true that there are
you know between
the concept of amount now take what's
the highest level
it's something that's invisible and
inaudible namely god right so
if you believe in god and i never
proselytize that's against my religion
to proselytize
but uh but in judaism like we believe
god is unseeable
you can't see him and you can't hear him
directly
and if you do you're supposed to go to
see a psychiatrist or you know
check yourself into a mentality but um
but that's the whole point and so when
i'm at synagogue or temple or whatever
you know it's always harder for me to
keep my mind on the invisible inaudible
god than it is to look at my wife or my
wife's beautiful voice or listen to
so yeah i don't think it's and and by
the way it could be for women too i
don't know i don't know what that
experience is
so i don't think it's necessarily sexist
i think it's necessarily
capitulating to the fact that the human
mind has such a hard job
conceptualizing god at all that almost
it would be better to be in like a
sensory deprivation tank
than anything else yeah yeah and also
like i don't know if this
this this relate but like when you're
younger like when you're just
born the first thing you hear about
other than the doctor
and the nurses before you you know your
your your eyes
you know it's open you probably hear
your mom voice first that's right
they can hear their voice your parents
voices the babies can sense the parents
voices inside the womb
and they certainly can't see anything
you know i i i always ask my kids what's
your earliest memory
it's not like oh i remember you telling
me the schrodinger equation
uh when i was a five-month gestation
that
[Music]
speaking of judaism i want to ask you
some of the questions that i ask all my
guests that come on it's not really
specific to judaism
but but there's a concept in judaism of
an ethical
will something that you want to give to
people in terms of wisdom
you are what i consider you know like
kind of pan cultural
uh that you you know you've been in so
many different cultures you've adapted
to so many different things we'll get to
like your life advice
to your former self later on today but
but i want to know like
what you've learned so far from from
your your experiences in america
um you know working with james obviously
but even things outside of working with
james i'm interested in you specifically
what wisdom have you learned that you
want to give to the future
not on terms of you know monetary you
know bequeathing
something financially but what do you
want to give the world in terms of
wisdom i know you're young but
but still you you've constructed you've
done you've had so many experiences
and my question is what kind of wisdom
could you distill as a
as an inheritance as a will for future
generations
oh so i don't know if this i don't know
if this is important at all but at least
it's important for me and
and uh i stood by uh pretty much
once i got here to the state is that you
know be a
be able to be be able to be able to
be able to adapt into in any situations
and
effects flexible or or if you
if you're born in the western country
make sure you spend some time in asia
country because western culture and
asian culture
are two different things but they should
be combined into one to make a whole you
know
like my perspective changed
so much one you know like i've been in
malaysia for my longest life so i lived
in malaysia for 24 years
so i always follow the asian rural asian
culture or whatever and then came here
and then i started seeing all this thing
and started learning and other things
all this thing and that sort of just
mowed me into who i am today is
to combine the western culture and
western
mentality with the asian culture and
asian mentality it's
you pick but of course you know you pick
the best of both you don't
just combine them all entirely you pick
the best of both
and um and be able to be flexible
that's actually very very very hard and
you know like it's very important
because
not ever like as i've seen a lot of
people that came from
from asia to here and they would just
stick to their way
they're like oh this is why i do things
it's how i do things i'm not going to
change my
my thing my in order to change
my lifestyle to feed other lifestyle and
then sooner or later it got depressed
and then they went back home
you know yeah so it's very important to
be able to adapt
to adapt to new ideas probably one of
the most important things
very nice um and we're doing again we're
talking with that uh with jay woodjun
yao
who is the uh super producer he
rocks the mic and the turntables he is
the dj that we turn to when we want to
bj
uh uh i want to talk about uh and of
course you're
very heavily acknowledged in james's new
book um i want to ask you well let me
ask you first do you believe
you've heard me kind of be bearish and
negative about extraterrestrials
you've heard avi loeb a professor at
harvard bullish do you think a
there are extraterrestrials and b do you
think that
we're living in a simulation where do
you come down on those two
okay so i'm a huge fan of superheroes
movie
and superhero comics obviously i would
hope that
we will have you know some sort of you
know uh you know
uh alien that wear red tight you know
and blue
blue tights or whatever but i i
maybe there is i mean for i mean i'm not
a physicist you know i mean
you're a scientist of uh physicist
obviously you know better than me but
like
for me um life
would mean differently outside of the
earth
i would say you know maybe what we
consider life-form or carbon-based
life-form
would be different in in you know
outside of earth it could
be something that maybe doesn't need
oxygen maybe it doesn't need
air maybe it doesn't need water but they
maybe they are leaving or maybe they are
not leaving
you know living is just uh just just
just uh
just just living is subjective right you
can
the tree is leaving you know the rock
could be living too know
you know for all we know but we they're
just not moving or
there's no way to find yeah no way to
define their
their their their livingness or
like i'm not sure i don't know if you
have seen this experiment
like someone someone take two glasses of
water
one they say gratitude stuff to the
water and the others one they just like
you know
uh yell at the water or say negative
into the water and then
um and then i don't know somehow they
crystallize it and then they put it
under microscope that
they both are very different the one
that they wanted
was given the the the gratitude and you
know appreciations
form more beautiful than the other one i
i don't know if you have seen the
experiment no i
it sounds a little suspicious to me but
uh yeah i mean i could be wrong you know
it could be some
some buzzfeed stuff that i read
somewhere but right
yeah but i yeah but i always you know
believe in you know like like living's
probably just
subjective you know everyone's right
it's hard to define that
and are we living in simulations
i heavily believe we we're living in
simulations maybe because i'm a gamer so
i sort of see the sign
okay or something like that but i i do
believe
uh we're living in uh simulations
because
why would you spawn into that body
and then everyone else could be uh what
i call end pieces none non-player
control
non-player character you know so i don't
know
i really don't know your favorite game
in terms of like the one that
most expands your mind i mean i keep in
mind i i don't play many
uh computer games but but for which one
is like because i know
my kids get really wrapped up in
minecraft and there's this meta layer
where it actually relates to physicists
and and so forth to think about these
con
issues of consciousness that you were
just talking about anyway what for you
let me ask you two questions what is
there a game that you could recommend to
me
knowing that i have a limited amount of
time and bandwidth
that is so important like you got me on
clubhouse and
you thought that was so important for me
and you were right and i thank you for
that and now we did james as well so now
it's leveraging all this
but is there anything that would benefit
my brain
my capacity or whatever and i'm just
ignorant of it because i don't follow
that
aspect of technology well i mean
games there's a couple way of looking at
games so
do you want to play for the story so
like
for me i only play two categories of
games uh
maybe three two uh two main categories
is one
is story driven like like you know you
read books
to no story to units you you know you
read to
to learn stories for me i
learned sorry for playing from playing
games you know you know how
how people say like you know you you
live a thousand different life if you
play if you if you read books for me i
live thousand life by playing games
that's like you know a lot of
games out there that i just love their
stories that story is so beautiful
um and then the other one it's because
you know obviously right right now we
are adults so i only have limited time
to play
so i will play games that's sort of a
competitive but casual at the same time
yeah i can play and then it's done and i
can reset again i can play again
so for the story one uh
one of my favorite is called bioshock
infinite
because they export alternate reality
and multiverse
uh in that game uh i'm gonna spoil it to
you
towards the end towards the end uh they
just
say that you know each stars it's a
portal to a different universe
yeah so so they came up with this
technology to pull different people
to pull the same person from different
universe to their universe
to you know to achieve whatever plan
they have
right so it oh yeah so that needs them
to go to gamestop
and they have to pick up the stock yeah
and then well
now and stuff like that but yeah that
game just blew my mind
and then uh and then uh i i just love
science
since i was younger so like just like
you know anything that
they have to do with science and they
put the two of them together
yeah yeah you got time for one or two
more questions oh yeah yeah okay great
good
good um so you know in your
in this experience and kind of like
thinking about technology
uh and its exponential growth um but
also kind of its hazards and sort of the
negative stuff that you've seen by proxy
i mean i was hurt
you know when james was attacked
assailed criticized by jerry seinfeld
this summer um when you're dealing with
that i see you as
as a very valuable role you're not only
a sounding board
you contribute you're a star character
you are a player character
on the json situation but do you
sometimes feel a little bit of a burden
jay
as as if you're a therapist uh i mean we
can all be therapists by the way i mean
i have a
strength therapist that's a personal
trainer at least i used to
if you can't tell but uh but do you feel
like you you are kind of a coach or a
therapist in a certain way
uh not really are he to you
he to me for sure for james to me that's
for sure like every time
um he almost like a father figure to me
you know like i will
i will talk about stuff and then i'll
ask him for advice it would give me a
great advice
for me i i think i'm a bad
influencer and enabler he's like oh i
just want to play chess i'm like yeah
sure let's play chess
let's let's let's watch you who play
chess and then we just play i was just
there
we just talk and then you play chess but
but you know
my role is pretty much just like okay
what is james
wasting time on right now and i can turn
that into content so jim's been playing
a lot of chats
a lot like a huge amount of chats i'm
like wow you should just
stream is just start streaming on twitch
and then he's like no no and then i keep
you know of course you know i i i keep
saying like you should stream you should
stream keep streaming keep streaming
so i managed to get him stream a couple
times on twitch
so that actually turned into content you
know which you saw it on
on the twitter yeah yesterday so
so like i realized you know like if
james want to do something that's
nothing that
we can stop him from doing it so that's
why that's why
being being able to adapt and be
flexible
is very important is that okay he has
he's going to do that thing no matter
what anyway so i just think
i have to think of a way to turn
what he's doing into content or you know
or something that at least i can put it
out there or we can put it out there
so like anything can be monetized
anything can be content you know so
yeah so that that's just me so like i
just trying to see
like how i can help james because james
has helped me
tremendously so my my role is to make
sure i
able to help james grow and you do you
do a phenomenal job
um and the last question i have i ask
all the guests
that honor me by their presence on the
into the impossible podcast
relates to uh the name of the podcast in
the following sense and i think you'll
resonate with some of these laws that
arthur c
clarke set up and put forth many many
decades ago
the first one is that any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and this
is a
a quote that i think someone in
technology in game playing etc
the stuff that you see now you know it's
like futuristic
sometimes comes true uh in the in the
not so distant future so that's
certainly true
the other thing we talk about a lot is
like what does it mean to be an expert
and uh arthur c clarke said for every
expert there's an
equal and opposite expert so
that's kind of funny to me that you know
one person will say something and if
we never just take oh you're a scientist
yeah okay isaac newton i'm not going to
investigate general relativity
you know galileo i'll just take our uh
einstein i'll just take your word for it
no we always want to question the
experts right
but yeah his third law is um really
relates to
advice to your former self and the
question the way i phrase it is
basically the name of this podcast he
arthur clark used to say
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible so
which you think is impossible you must
try to venture into and so that's the
name of the podcast
i want to ask you when you were half
your current age
um was there a piece of advice or some
knowledge
that you could give to the younger you
know jay junio
and then that something will be possible
only if he has the courage strength
stamina
hit points whatever to go into the
impossible
um always ask the girl that you you have
crush on
out always the thing is uh it's more
like
always ask so uh
asian culture i mean maybe it's just me
um
we are afraid of us like we are afraid
of rejection
uh which is we just i i would say like
50
of the people out there always you know
afraid of rejections uh
you know um you know what so like
i'm pretty sure i missed a lot of
opportunity by just not asking by just
by just assuming they will say no so
these two things i will tell to my
younger self
is always ask and never assume anything
like like i would i wouldn't i wouldn't
like so if i
if i want to hang out with you tomorrow
i will still
i will ask right now you know i wouldn't
assume like uh
bro tomorrow is friday brian's probably
be busy you know doing blah blah
i would just ask you know so yeah ask is
very important
and never assume anything and never
expect
and didn't expect anything that's really
brilliant um
i'm glad you said that because there are
uh there have been studies done that i
read
there were famous accident that took
place in a korean airlines plane in san
francisco
about five or six years ago maybe more
and
they found they traced a lot of the root
cause to the co-pilot
who was really smart and very
knowledgeable but he was scared to kind
of
ask quite like are you sure you want to
land without the landing gear or
whatever they did
wrong or just by this instrument
approach during perfect weather
conditions
and they said at least at korean
airlines now we we know that
you know that malaysia is very different
of course but but i think
i like everything what's that malaysia's
airplane always is gone missing you know
we don't ask questions yeah i don't talk
about malaysian airplanes
but we shouldn't joke but but the point
being that the uh
that you know kind of yeah we should all
take that advice because
you know i wouldn't have gotten people
to uh to come on my show
even get connected to james you know i
got connected to james we did a ted talk
together tedx san diego back in uh
back in the uh about five or six years
ago and we met each other and i had been
listening to him for a long time really
liked him a lot
and we uh and i tried to connect to him
just back and you know but i didn't
really
i didn't have any urgency shall we say
and then
later earlier last year in 2020 i got
connected to jordan harbinger
who's a mutual friend a podcaster as
well and
and uh jordan had me on his show and
after like two years of negotiation
basically like i had to submit all this
stuff and all these comments and it just
took a really long time
uh and and it was definitely worth it
because jordan's got a huge audience
huge platform
podcaster of the year 2018 like his
personal nobel prize in your grammy
but um but then i said look uh you know
i'm sure people ask you to be connected
to guests all the time
i'm happy to connect you to whatever
guest i have if you're interested
uh jordan usually turns me down because
he thinks uh
a lot of my guests except for this one
he's gonna ask me for a connection to
you i'm sure
uh he he you know he's talked about kobe
bryant and
president clinton or whatever so he's
got pretty high level guests but anyway
uh i said i'm only going to ever ask you
for one introduction and so far i've
kept this
my word uh and i said i want to be
reintroduced to james altitude
and jordan did and you know thanks to
that
uh which uh which took you know two or
three years in the making
you and i are having this conversation
so not being afraid to ask and and that
and
and uh and putting it out there because
it risks vulnerability
it risks production and so i think you
know i
i can't envision you as a shy or timid
but i take your word for it that you
might you must have been
but it's a salute to you that you've
grown as a human being
and you've benefited by as we say going
into the impossible and jay i want to
thank you
i love talking to you i'll probably talk
to you uh in a couple of days uh and
it's just so much fun i've learned i
learned from you
and uh and you're just yeah you're a
real you're such a professional
and i know you're gonna if you don't win
the grammy you get a book out of it
losing the grammy prize
i'll help you right now yeah yeah okay
and i can't wait to do more things
together you're so much
you're one of the bright spots that i
get to look forward to whenever we chat
that's a bonus
i get a side bonus when i talk to james
i get to talk to jake yeah yeah
it's like it's like a side dish you know
you have to hear the main cards and you
have the
side dish or the dessert i don't mind
doing that
that's right all right jay would you
thank you so much have a great day say
hi to new york city go and get me a
kosher sausage dunkin donuts sandwich
and i just edited this morning
oh you did awesome my so every day
so on weekdays friday to monday to
friday every day morning my breakfast
is kosher sausage with coffee and a
donut
oh my god oh you're making me you're
making me pine for my ancestral homeland
your
your homeland and my homeland will unite
them together i hope we can see each
other in person this year maybe
yeah yeah maybe you should come out to
new york because um
a block from me there's this place
called barney green brass
oh that's famous yeah the famous jewish
place yeah i have only been there once
because
i moved here uh and then six months
later
lockdown started so yeah i walked by it
i gained ten pounds from the locks and
the schmidt
and the bagel you get the bag of breath
and you get the
you gain five pounds uh jay i can't wait
to do that in person i'm really looking
forward to meeting you in person someday
okay thank you for having me bye jay
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
foreign